[Music]
everyone there's a Steve Lyme job with
collider I'm here at the Kia Telluride
supper sweet talking to Chelsea Harris
are you doing I'm good
matter of fact I'm great the thing is so
I want we're going to talk about
snowpiercer and Picard yes and but the
funny thing is with both of these things
you can talk and basically say nothing
so it's like it's extreme I know you
were absolutely right it's the funniest
thing is because everybody especially
when it comes to snowpiercer people are
like so so like is this before the thumb
or is this after the thumb because you
know snowpiercer was babies Oh 100% of
atomic you sound like you're a fan I
have amilia with this material I like
you already which I like you yeah and so
I mean there's so many things that I
want to be able to tell people because
it's so good but I can't I understand so
let's start with Picard because I've not
seen the premiere yet next generations
one of my all-time favorite shows I
could not be more excited for this show
so let's talk about are you in the
premiere oh my so actually no I'm not in
the premiere but my episodes start
airing next week oh yeah so let's talk
about actually booking the gig because
you can how much did you know about Star
Trek and let's start with that okay so I
have to be super honest and say that
growing up Star Trek was always on TV
because I grew up in Georgia and came on
after the Simpsons and before x-files
but I I never really got into it when I
was younger just because I don't know I
just I was watching Disney Channel yeah
but when I did get this job and I went
back and I had almost an entire month to
watch old episodes from next generation
and I was actually blown away how
relevant those episodes still are the
storylines the things that the people
were going through I'm I'm I was like
holy cow how did how did I get this how
did I get this for people that have
never seen next generation which is
disappointing I strongly recommend
binging it I think it's on Netflix huh
it's such an if you said it's still so
timely yeah because the issues they were
dealing with
you know sci-fi is a great metaphor you
can you know that's exactly it and I
didn't become a huge sci-fi fan up until
at the very beginning of last year when
you know when I got this opportunity and
it's funny because snowpiercer also
being sci-fi and I think one of the
reasons why I was able to also get that
job is because I fell in love with the
genre because of the fact that you can
talk about things in the genre that you
can't just like necessarily openly talk
about in such an easy way but it's a
metaphor right a hundred percent yeah
one of the reasons why I'm so excited
about Picard besides you know Patrick
Stewart and all the normal stuff is
Michael Chabon as a writer I mean he's a
genius so I definitely want to talk
about the scripts and maybe what
surprised you about these scripts versus
maybe what you were expecting well you
know something that's actually really
interesting so when you are recurring on
Star Trek Picard they don't give you all
of the scripts because they don't want
you to like know any spoilers and so the
fun thing is outside of the episodes
that I have gotten the opportunity to do
I'm also going to be an audience member
watching to find out everything that
happens to you when you were getting the
scripts for the episodes you're in did
they provide the whole script they did
okay so that they did got it yeah and I
can tell you that the scripts are
incredible even though I wasn't able to
you know know everything that was going
on in the series it's just one of those
things that where it captures you and
it's so much fun watching to see how
Picard I mean you know it's
he's like retired and he's being called
back into you know back into and to his
old his old path that was my favorite
thing actually getting to see how he is
aged and getting to see how his
passionate so they are getting to see
the conflict that he has of of you know
I stepped away from this I no longer
want it is I'm wanting to do this but I
have two hundred can you reveal what how
many you're in or is it one of these
things you have to be quiet about can I
gotta be quiet about it I got it are you
allowed to talk about your character
that I also have to be quiet about yes
basically in like a few days I could
have asked you more specific questions I
understand no it's totally fine maybe
talk a little bit about what surprised
you on the set about working on the show
that's actually my favorite thing sorry
didn't mean oh it's fine I get excited
about this because of the fact that
again this is my first step into sci-fi
and so when I arrived to set that day my
very first scene had like you know 65
backgrounds in it but all of the
backgrounds are all different types of
you know species of aliens and so every
single one of them every single one of
them it's actually probably more like
120 not 65 that day I was like a hundred
and twenty background and every single
one of them was in some type of full
prosthetics custom-made costumes this
set is one of the most unbelievably
gorgeous things that I've ever seen the
the attention to detail was like
mind-blowing and so as an artist to get
to step on to that set and I mean it's
like you can't really step out of the
world right sure I actually want to
interrupt and just ask a simple question
yeah how much did you pay to be on
Picard I've you know well I was paid to
be on so I've deduced as a sci-fi fan
your first scene is in a space station
or at the Federation so is it a space
station or the Federation I can't I'm
just teasing one of the things that I
was super excited by next generation is
I loved Whoopi Goldberg as Guinan and I
just saw on the view yes the Patrick
Stewart surprised her and said would you
like to be part of season two and did
you hear her answer I did I thought she
was crying she was crying yes she was
very emotional so talk a little bit
about maybe like Whoopi Goldberg liked
having her on that show meant a lot to a
lot of people talk about that yeah I
mean it meant a lot to me too again like
I said I wasn't a huge Star Trek fan
back in the day but that was actually
something that I was very well aware of
when I was a kid that she was that
character and was very well aware of the
fact that that you know you don't see a
lot of women that looked like me and
those types of positions
back then and so for her getting to come
back to the show I'm super excited to
see where they go with this script what
they do with her character and I
actually did get to see one of the
executive producers earlier this weekend
and she was like yeah Whoopi said a
definite yes I'm pretty sure what's
happening yeah so yeah well I mean I'm
what they got greenlit for the second
season and obviously you need to know
when you're writing scripts whether or
not you have a major character like I've
never seen that before though asking
someone to come back on national TV well
I mean it's Sir Patrick he can do
whatever he wants to do you know he can
literally do whatever he wants to do but
he did say he did preface it by saying
that Alex Kurtzman who works on the show
gave me permission to ask you this he
did say that and so it was like a kind
of a chain of command things where yeah
where wasn't just like he's just
blurting this out heywhat but you want
to come back completely I'm now
wondering if Whoopi's agent that day was
super excited to snowpiercer so that has
not premiered yet but he had a panel
here at Sundance and I believe it's
already been picked up for a second
season yep so which is where you come in
yeah that's where I come in
so I will also say that as an actor
that's the first time that I've ever
heard of that happening where a show or
the executives of a show loved it so
much the network loved it so much that
they said let's do a second season
before the first even comes out so yeah
it will be coming out TNT May 31st
that's first season and yeah second
season that's where I come in yeah it's
crazy because the one advantage to this
though is that you've started filming
season two yep halfway through it I was
gonna say the advantage to this
obviously there's VFX in this show with
train going through the world the way it
is but it also I would imagine it allows
the second season two premiere maybe
sooner or it definitely allows it to hit
in May of the following year yeah I mean
that's my hope I hope that we're not
gonna have to wait too terribly long for
season two to drop especially because of
the fact
well because I'm on it but also just
because it really is such a fantastic
show that the the cast we have Jennifer
Connelly as one of our main stars of the
show we have daveed Diggs from Hamilton
we have Lena Hall it was also an
incredibly Otoniel an incredible Tony
award-winning actress as well I mean we
have just in such an incredible cast but
even more so we have an incredible
writer who is really taking off with
this that's Grand Mason and he's our
showrunner he also did orphan black and
the man is just brilliant and it's one
of those things where I know they have
an idea of like where things are going
but he's always watching on set to see
like oh you know he's getting ideas
right where if he sees like oh you kind
of have this like little type of
relationship with this actor over here
let's see what we can do with that in
terms of putting that into some of the
scripts down the line exactly they are
but you get on set the yeah can you
reveal anything about your character or
is it super guarded it's super guarded
and when season 2 comes out you will
understand why I won't pressure you what
have you seen yourself of season 1 and
maybe what because I would imagine yeah
how much do they show you before filming
season 2 you know so I actually didn't
see much of season 1 before season 2
I've seen like different extended clips
I haven't seen any full episodes but
everything that I have seen like just
blown away by yeah and it's um I want to
say to that one of my favorite things
about it the TV show especially what I
have seen of season 1 if you read the
graphic novel which you have I have one
of the things that they address there
which is how the people got in the tail
and in the film they didn't really show
that but on the TV show we actually do
show that I have so many more questions
about snowpiercer but uh so it's so
tricky when you you know what I mean you
drill down and get those things so I
guess where are you filming and when do
you wrap yeah so filming in Vancouver
I said we're halfway through season two
right now and wrapping at the end of
March okay very soon
oh yeah but you're still on it on it so
uh oh yeah I flew here directly from
Vancouver okay well I'm gonna stop there
and say I sincerely cannot wait to see
what you're doing on Picard and I'll be
very mad that I didn't address certain
things after I see the episode this week
you know what I can say I'm a trill and
that's all I can say that's all I was
like everybody in the room there I could
say that that's also I mean look at that
over there is a very big Star Trek fan
just like me
so for for ya I'm not gonna get you in
trouble I'm not gonna drill down but
we'll do doing a follow-up on that note
thank you so much for coming by
and I really cannot wait to see it